LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
Before I worked here,
I always wondered
what it'd be like to
come to the Googleplex,
meet up with a Googler,
and have coffee with them
and just chat about what
they do, how they do it,
and why they do it.
Today, we're going to be
talking with Francis Ma, who's
a product manager
on the Android team.
And he's going to tell us all
about how you can build better
apps using Google Play services.
Francis, welcome.
It's good to have you here.
FRANCIS MA: Thanks, Laurence.
Nice to be here.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So one of the things
that, when we started
prepping for this episode
and we started saying, hey,
we're going to Francis Ma on,
every time I talked to a
Googler they were all like,
oh, you're going
to have Francis on!
I worked with him on this
and I worked with him
on that-- it seems like
you've been around the block.
Tell us about yourself
and what you do.
FRANCIS MA: So I've been working
at Google for a couple years
now.
And I've been fortunate enough
to work on different products.
Most recently, before
joining Android,
I was on the Google+ team
working on our social efforts.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
So it sounds like a lot of fun.
FRANCIS MA: Yeah, absolutely.
It's just great.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Today, now, you're
working on Google Play
services as part of your task.
Now what is this
Google Play services?
What does it do?
What's so cool about it?
FRANCIS MA: Google Play
services is a unified SDK
that we offer to Android
developers as a way for them
to integrate with Google
services and Google APIs.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So you say
it's a unified way that they
can access these
services and APIs.
How is it unified?
FRANCIS MA: So the idea
is that, as a developer,
you can get one SDK, which is
the Google Play services SDK,
and through that, you'll have
access to the various Google
platform APIs that we offer
from things like ads, analytics,
Google Wallet, et cetera.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
the design pattern
that I follow when
I'm coding-- something
for Maps and for
Wallets and for Ads--
it's going to be the
same because of this?
FRANCIS MA:
Absolutely, and that's
one of the ideas behind
Google Play services
when we started, was
we wanted to offer
a consistent experience
for Android developers
to be able to integrate
with various features
and functionalities
that Google offers.
So for example, if you
integrated with Google Maps
and then later on you choose
to integrate with Google
Analytics, the same
paradigm and the model of it
is very consistent so
that the learning curve,
you don't have to relearn
something entirely different.
And it's very convenient for
you to add more into your app.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's really cool.
So if I learn the methodology to
build Maps into my application,
that methodology's
going to transfer over
to-- I don't know
if I use location
or-- that's really, really cool.
I like it.
But you used a couple
of words there that kind
of sprung up in my mind,
like developer experience.
And developer
experience I know is
something that's very
important in Google.
And it's something that you're
particularly passionate about.
Can you tell us a
little bit about it
and what you're
doing in that space?
FRANCIS MA: When we
look at building an API,
we really look at
it as a product.
And an analogy of that, if
you were using a consumer app,
we would look at the
visual design of it,
the user experience of it.
What is it like to pick up
the app, install the app?
What's the [? onboard ?]
[? inflow, ?] et cetera?
Now you look at,
for developers, it's
not just about the API design,
but about the life cycle
of how developers
discover that API.
How do they learn about it?
How do you integrate it?
And how are you able to build
a successful app on top of it?
And so when we talk about
developer experience,
we really want to
think about end
to end such that we can
offer a delightful experience
for developers, to make it
easy for you to plug it in.
And earlier we touched on the
consistency as one example.
So the experience
of learning one API
makes it much more familiar
or easy for developers
to pick up the next.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So the Android
platform is very diverse.
There's a lot of
different versions.
And there's a lot of
things that developers
will need to learn to be
the best possible developer.
Is there anything that we're
doing in Google Play services
to make that easier for them?
FRANCIS MA: Yeah.
So Google Play services,
it's a little bit
different in that it works
across all major versions
of Android dating back to
version 2.3, the Gingerbread
release, and up.
So as a developer, once you
integrate with the Google Play
services' APIs,
we assure that it
works across all
of these devices,
helping you reach the 1
billion active Android
devices as a developer.
LAURENCE MORONEY: 1 billion.
FRANCIS MA: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And so
just to reinforce that,
just make sure I
understand you right,
if I build my application
using Google services
and using Google
Play services, then
it's going to work
on Gingerbread.
It's going to work on Kit Kat.
It's going to work on Honeycomb,
Lollipop, all of those things
without me needing
to change anything.
FRANCIS MA: Absolutely.
And another aspect of
Google Play services
is that we also provide
automatic updates.
So as an example, if
you integrated with,
let's say the location
API that we offer,
and over time if we come up
with a more optimal way of,
let's say, detecting location to
be able to offer more precision
and in a more
power-efficient manner,
you would get that
for free for your app.
So as a developer,
you integrate it once,
you don't have to
worry about it.
And you also are able to get
the update benefits as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: One
question I have to ask.
Like Android-- we've been
talking about funny names
like Kit Kat and
FroYo and Lollipop
and-- does Google Play services
have strange names like that?
FRANCIS MA: We go by cheeses.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cheeses?
FRANCIS MA: Yeah.
Alphabetically-ordered cheeses.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
FRANCIS MA: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That
must be hard to find names.
So what cheese are
we on right now?
FRANCIS MA: We are
on the N release.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
N. N. I can't think
of a cheese that
begins with an N.
FRANCIS MA: Yeah, well,
we cheated a bit there.
We have the Nacho Cheese.
So not quite a cheese, but
we call it the Nacho release.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Very good.
So after N then is
going to come O.
FRANCIS MA: It's going
to become O. Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Can you tell us
what cheese is going to be
the star of the next version?
FRANCIS MA: We are
calling the next one Orla.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Orla.
I've never heard of Orla cheese.
I'm going to have to go down to
my cheesemonger and buy some.
Then whenever you
shift, do you have
a party for when the new version
of the bits have been cut?
FRANCIS MA: Yeah, the
cheese-cutting party.
LAURENCE MORONEY: A party
where you cut the cheese?
FRANCIS MA: We do
buy the cheese.
And we gather and we'll share
it as a mini-celebration, yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
I'll have to look forward
to what Orla looks like.
FRANCIS MA: Yep.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
getting back to developers
now-- away from
cheeses for a moment--
we are very much living in
a mobile first world now,
and developers of
course have to live
in that world ahead
of everybody else.
And they have unique challenges
in the mobile first world.
It's very different from web
development or desktop or even
cloud development.
What kind of challenges do
you see developers facing?
And what are we doing to
make their lives easier?
FRANCIS MA: Yeah, absolutely,
I think building on mobile
is a very different challenge
than building on the web.
As an example, if
you think about it,
the code that you
deliver to end users
is running on a computer--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
A really small one.
FRANCIS MA: --that you
don't control, right?
The user might be
driving in some location
where the network
connectivity might be sparse.
The battery is a concern because
a user has that with them
on the go all day.
And so as a developer, you
really have to think about some
of these nuances from
a user's perspective,
and how do you
make that optimal.
How do you make it
so that it's fast
and make it work well on
the diversity of devices
that are out there?
And so with Google
Play services,
what will help you
is we think a lot
about optimizing
for mobile things
like offline connectivity
and so forth.
And so as a developer,
these are things
that you can worry less about
and focus more about how
you can differentiate
your app and really build
things and focus on
making your app great.
And let Google
help you solve some
of the fundamental problems
of building on mobile.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
So with building for
fundamentally a device that
sits in your pocket most of the
time, and it's a tiny device,
there are complex scenarios.
And with Google Play
services, you're
taking the complexity
out of those scenarios
and helping developers to
build better apps, as it were.
FRANCIS MA: Absolutely.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
What advice would you
have for developers
to get started
as the best possible
mobile developers today?
FRANCIS MA: Use
Google Play services.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Well, of course.
Any quick advantages that
they could reap right away?
FRANCIS MA: Absolutely.
As I touched on before, we
offer many Google services
through the same SDK.
So as an example,
integrating Google Analytics
is a really good way
for you to get insight
into what users are doing so
that you can get that feedback
and optimize your app
to build a better app.
Or another example is using
the fused location provider,
which we help you figure out
the best way to get the user's
location if you're building
a location-aware app.
And so you don't have to worry
about, do you use the GPS,
do you use Wi-Fi signals, and
all kinds of different things.
We just have the simple
location API for you,
and you can just
integrate that and focus
on things that
differentiate your app.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And then that
optimizes your battery, right,
so you're not overusing
it, that type of thing.
FRANCIS MA: Absolutely.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Well, Francis, thanks
for being here.
It's been great
talking with you.
I've learned a lot.
I hope the viewers have
learned a lot, too.
FRANCIS MA: My pleasure.
It's been fun.
LAURENCE MORONEY: All right.
So, everybody, this has been
another episode of "Coffee
with a Googler."
Thanks for watching this far.
If there are other
Googlers that you'd
like to have a conversation
with on this show,
please just let us know.
Drop us a line.
And you can watch all
the other episodes
of this show on the Google
Developers channel on YouTube.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]